it's just not the way to make the world
a better place look at jimmy kimmel
exactly jimmy kimmel was part of the
culture canceled culture man got a lot
of people canceled then finally
jimmy did he had a lot of stuff going on
and then people went hold on
hold up dude and they start looking he's
funny and making fun of people so his
job is to be satirical about it
i don't think he's cancelling people
like [ __ ] you no second chances you know
i mean
you'll look into it really yes that
makes me so sad
damn it
uh we have lost our minds
yes i agree i listen i don't think you
should be canceled for stuff he did
you know that old the car malone stuff
and when he was doing a rap song with
snoop dogg
use the n-word that's not why you cancel
him no but i'm saying if you're if
you're gonna
if you're gonna be a proponent of cancel
culture it's gonna come back around
it's gonna come back around but also
things were different everybody's moving
in
we're trying to figure this out you know
they're they're i'm old enough to
remember when things were so different
when gay marriage was considered
outrageous well i'm old enough to
remember when when the idea that you
two gay people could raise a kid instead
of being in foster care was outrageous
and i believed that i was like no that's
you can't have that
and then a woman who had two gay parents
argued me
into like a different point of view i
didn't know i'd never
barely met any gay people until i was in
theater school i didn't [ __ ] know
i had stereotypical ideas i was and i
i'm not i'm not dumb
but i was young and i was [ __ ]
ignorant
but i've changed my mind that's possible
you can become a better [ __ ] person
and you should be allowed to become a
better person like it's
it's just like uh you know with jimmy
fallon
you you also talk about a different time
when when jimmy fallon
and jimmy kimmel do anything should come
out a different time yeah again how far
do you want to go back
do you want to get rid of all uh you
know uh john wayne movies
because i know but but corporations are
you know corporations
are are literally getting rid of people
and that's what's so scary that it's
it's it's
they're just like saying you can't work
anymore what is he supposed to do
what the [ __ ] is he supposed to do he
did it on your network
or whatever it was you know i just i'm
i mean it doesn't make the world a
better place this behavior it does not
it does not it doesn't
you you're you're just full of [ __ ] and
it's
the nail on the head because you know
because he's not part of a major network
you know he says uh corolla about the
night effect the black face on black
americans
um they should look at everything in
context what is going on
we're gonna have to start speaking about
difference between what the
intent is you know what's funny like
here he goes was there a news hanging
bubble
what uh wallace's garage yes there was
was it meant for him
no it wasn't it was actually for the
race right so let's put it
so you could say there's a there's a
noose there yeah and we freak out and
let's
cancel nascar let's cancel this and make
bubble wallace the hero yup was there a
news
if you just look at the headlines yes
was it there as a
car garage and they all have ropes yes
yeah
so it's again it's it's it's but it's
commercial but of course it's context
it's context and it's intention what was
your context what was your intention if
you take that away
you're a [ __ ] idiot and they're
coming for you next and nobody wants to
live in a world like that
and i don't and it has to be fought
against has to be voiced against
it is it is madness this is the madness
of crowds
but the madness but here's when you say
crowds remember
150 people are on twitter you're right
but the corporations listen to these
[ __ ] people
corporations like like these big
corporations get rid of people because
they it's about their bottom line
and they're they're not they're not
behaving
yeah i will say in 1950 1960 1970 and
even in 1980 and maybe
beginning in 1990 if you were found out
to be gay
at your workplace you could be fired you
would have your life ruined you could
have so
so there a lot of this stuff is now a
push
in the opposite direction but human
beings love to be tyrannical and they
love
to do this but it used to be that being
gay was illegal
it used to be that being gay was
dangerous dude used to be the being gay
was a liability 100
i'll tell you this right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue
okay what's going to happen what are you
going to do
use some of that boxing you've been
doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespected